je vous parle aujourd'hui d'un
accessoire pour tablettes c'est quelque
chose que je fais très rarement mais
c'est un produit vraiment intéressant je
suggérer quelques temps c'est l'apple
magic qui bordent pour ipad pro
transforme votre ipad pro en un petit
ordinateur voire carrément un grand
ordinateur car en un ordinateur
il ouvre de nouvelles perspectives mais
ce qui est un peu dingue c'est que j'ai
jamais vu autant de hay autour d'un
accessoire pour tablettes même si c'est
une belle tablette même si c'est un bel
accessoire quand j'ai commencé à
travailler là dessus je me suis dit je
vais faire une vidéo où je vais vous
parler du nouvel ipad frau je vous
parlais du magic qui bordent qui va avec
je vous faire une vidéo complète et je
me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
beaucoup trop de choses à dire sur ce le
magic qui bordent que la vidéo allait
être beaucoup trop longue
j'ai donc préféré la split et
aujourd'hui on traite du magic qui borde
d'apple
on traitera des sites quelques jours de
la campagne pro dont je vous invite dès
maintenant à vous abonner pour tout
savoir sur la prochaine vidéo et
d'activer la cloche si ce n'est pas déjà
le cas je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant j'utilise des ipad depuis
beaucoup d'années il ya quelques mois
j'ai eu un ipad trop c'est plus
j'utilise beaucoup j'aime beaucoup ce
format je trouve vraiment intéressant
mais il lui manquait un petit quelque
chose et ce petit quelque chose apple
vient de l'année au travers de cet
accessoire là qui malgré tout rester un
accessoire très onéreux mais ça je vous
dirai à la fin de la vidéo
peut-être que vous connaissez déjà le
prix tout de suite il n'y a pas grand
secret là dessus mais ça nous fait un
combo tout de suite relativement cher
néanmoins il ya un vrai usage derrière
il ya de vrais beaux usage derrière je
dirais même et puis surtout on a un
produit qui est très bien fait une
fabrication très solide et extrêmement
rassurante
vous le mettez dans le sens que vous
voulez vous pouvez le payer comme vous
voulez salle sent planer la robustesse
on se dit pas que ce produit va nous
lâcher et au contraire il est là pour
supporter un ipad pro qui carmen
relativement lourd et bien je puis vous
assurer que la mission est vraiment
rempli et que de ce côté là aussi apple
tient vraiment sa promesse c'est magique
qui bordent vraiment mener l'ipad pro
dans une toute nouvelle dimension
les finitions sont vraiment
irréprochable vous pouvez venir régler
l'angle de visionnage la raison pour
laquelle vous n'avez pas de pros eh bien
ce sont les usages que vous allez en
avoir au quotidien quels sont vos goûts
vos usages avec votre ipad frau si vous
en avez un ou si vous comptez 1 acheté à
marquer deux mois en bas en commentaire
est la toute première chose ça va être
l'aspect bureautique vous avez vous
n'avez pas de pros vous avez beaucoup de
performances vous l'utilisez pour faire
de la bureautique que ce soit ou word
excel tout le pack office de
email pour travailler vous êtes vraiment
sûr de la productivité je vous fais pas
tout de suite le test de l'ipad pro
puisque ça on le verra plus tard
mais ce magic qui bord vient vraiment
permettre à syfy pro de rentrer dans une
autre dimension par rapport à ces usages
là et c est pour moi un des intérêts
primordiaux de ce produit c'est que vous
avez un format paysage vous avez un
clavier qui est là bien réel bien
physique et ça vous permet de faire des
choses que vous ne faisiez pas de façon
très pratique avant alors il existait
bien évidemment des claviers bluetooth
vous pouvez le connecter à votre ipad
il fallait aller dans vos paramètres
acquis belle 12 entre un bon ça rajouter
des contraintes supplémentaires
néanmoins n'ayant pas de solutions
développées par apple ça fonctionne et
ça fonctionne eden plutôt très bien là
vous avez quelque chose qui est vraiment
bien et qui répond bien évidemment cette
problématique car alors avant de vous
développer qu'il avait dans quelques
instants
on va continuer avec nos usages pour moi
les âges multimédia c'est vraiment un
des points forts il est fixé il est posé
vous le calais comme vous voulez si vous
êtes dans votre lit chez vous pouvez le
caler sur un petit coup ça il va pas
tomber il est en place si vous voulez
faire de la retouche photo par exemple
peut venir l'utiliser bien évidemment
même s'il vous pouvez aisément utiliser
aussi l'utiliser avec votre clavier
moi qui suis habitué à travailler sur un
macbook pro bien je puis vous assurer
que cette habitude là ne convient bien
avec la dernière version de l'ipad ios
je peux bien modifier les réglages très
facilement façon complètement intuitive
vous pourrez également faire du montage
vidéo vous pourrez faire de la musique
la création musicale et si vous êtes
infographie bien vous pouvez prendre
votre stylet et venir travailler dessus
sans aucun problème mais ça uniquement
en format paysage si vous voulez
travailler au format portrait et bien
vous prenez votre tablette
vous la mettez comme ça et là vous venez
bosser cette manière là bon gignac
si vous voulez vraiment bosser votre
portrait et vous n'y arrivez pas eh bien
vous prenez votre ipad vous le posez
comme ça c'est peut-être pas idéal mais
ça fera très bien la faire et c'est là
où c'est accessoire prend tout son sens
c'est pas qu'il va transformer votre
ipad en un ordinateur il à faire bien
plus que ça ça vous permettra d'avoir
une tablette que vous allez pouvoir
utiliser format paysage format portrait
que vous allez pouvoir venir à calais ça
vous sert également un peu de cheval et
si vous voulez pas utiliser le clavier
vous pouvez l'utiliser avec le clavier
pour venir travailler ça peut aussi
venir tout simplement stabiliser un peu
l'histoire et croyez moi pour me recaler
un ipad si vous n'aviez pas le bon et tu
es bien des fois c'est un petit peu
galère et notamment lorsque vous allez
venir travailler avec votre apple pencil
elias apportera vraiment plus c'est pas
du tout un produit qui fait pour être
utilisée de cette manière là vous n'avez
pas
37 pas utilisé comme ça c'est pas comme
une smart cover un petit peu classique
on est sur tout autre chose
on a ici un clavier rétro éclairé on
trouve très facilement l'emplacement des
touches le toucher vraiment très
agréable et elles ont une course qui est
relativement courte
on pourrait se dire que j'arrive au
niveau des chiffres je viens de cogner
bon si vous voulez vous cognez c'est que
vraiment vous le cherchez puisque votre
mois va pas de calais complètement à
l'avant mais plutôt au milieu donc ça
c'est quand même extrêmement pratique à
utiliser
on a un trackpad qui va pas être le
trackpad le plus grand il plus large qui
contourne habitués aux derniers macbook
pro néanmoins il est quand même
relativement large et occupe une grande
partie de l'espace ici et l'offre une
expérience qui est vraiment bien
maîtrisée d'autant plus que vous avez
partout du clic quel que soit l'endroit
où vous allez appuyer et bien vous avez
un clic et c'est là où ipad ios est
extrêmement bien fichu puisque vous
pouvez naviguer à plusieurs doigts bien
évidemment pouvez venir vous déplacer
très facilement dans votre page mais
vous pouvez changer de page
en naviguant à deux doigts très
facilement pour trouver tout ce que vous
voulez trouver pour ouvrir et vous
suffit de cliquer un doigt mais si vous
appuyez à deux doigts et bien vous avez
un clic droit et ici vous aurez accès à
toutes vos options vous allez bien
évidemment pour faire défiler vos pages
avec vos deux doigts ça c'est un grand
classique mais avec trois droit hop vous
revenez à l'écran d'accueil trois doigts
voulait s'appuyer
vous avez votre multitouch trois doigts
et vous ressortez ça c'est pas mal mais
il ya aussi des petits raccourcis à
connaître comme commandes et tab qui
vous permettra de venir switcher entre
vos différentes applications pour y
accéder extrêmement rapidement et si
vous voulez savoir quels sont tous les
raccourcis disponibles voulait s'appuyer
sur la touche commandes et ça vous
affichera à l'image des raccourcis
disponible pour l'application dans
laquelle vous êtes donc vous voyez le
combo entre le magic qui borde et ipad
ios a vraiment été réfléchie par apple
permet d'aller le plus loin faire plus
de choses mais malgré tout il manque
quand même deux trois petits trucs
la première chose qui va manquer et qui
pour moi m'a semblé bizarre dès le
départ c'est le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
de touches escape j'étais en train de
regarder une vidéo j'aurai à faire
quelque chose je veux pouvoir sortir de
là je cherchais ma touche et skype elle
n'existe pas alors il ya des gestes à
apprendre à une fois qu'on les a après
une fois qu'on les a intégrés et bien on
oublie ce problème touche et skype mais
quand on arrive d'un macbook pro ou d'un
macbook air et bien je puis vous assurer
que l'on se pose un peu là question la
même chose il nous manque des petites
touches fonction pouvoir régler la
luminosité de l'écran pouvoir régler la
luminosité du
clavier pouvoir régler le son alors
régler le son mais évidemment on a des
petits boutons sur le dessus et sans
doute comprendrais très rapidement mais
sont tous les petits réflexes qu'on a
avec un ordinateur et notamment avec un
macbook pro avec la cchb art et lorsque
vous arrivez sur le magic qui bordent de
l'ipad pro et bien sûr des choses qui
vous manque un peu est ce que ça
pourrait potentiellement arriver sur une
version future ou alors est-ce qu'il
faut vraiment s'habituer à utiliser
l'ipad pro avec le magic qui borde
différemment de ce qu'on peut faire avec
un macbook pro notamment à macao du bar
bon après soyez rassurés la luminosité
vous et devenir la règle et en allant
dans réglages vous allez dans général
vous allez dans clavier vous allez dans
clavier physique
et là vous avez quelques petites options
vous pouvez notamment venir régler la
luminosité de votre clavier par des fois
devenir s'ajuster par rapport à la
luminosité de votre pièce et pourraient
venir modifier des touches la touche
globe par exemple ou à venir choisir
d'assigner une touche et notamment la
touche escape
c'est une possibilité après à vous de
voir vous pouvez aller plus loin en
termes de personnalisation
moi je suis quand même vachement bluffé
par sa sensation extrêmement robuste
qu'on peut avoir lorsqu'on vient prendre
lorsqu'on va l'enlever
à aucun moment au diktat ipad pro va
tomber on connaît la qualité des
produits apple est une fois de plus ils
n'ont pas dérogé à la règle avec une
telle étude fabrication qui est vraiment
bien vous pouvez bien réglée très
facilement de 90 degrés à 130° donc ça
s'est vraiment bien pétain est d'être un
point un peu négatif c'est que lorsqu'il
est fermé comme ça et si vous le poser
sur une table
eh ben il est pas hyper simple wavriens
vraiment venir europe le prendra demain
c'est un peu l'inconvénient de ce type
d'ouverture mais qui malgré tout ce
qu'on prend extrêmement rapidement et on
a pris cool c'est pas non plus parfait
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
qui pèse relativement lourd
le magic qui bordent pèse quelque chose
comme 6 190 grammes tandis qu'on n'aille
pas trop pèse à peu près 6 145 g on
arrive sur un poids de 1335 g
les deux autant vous dire que le magic
qui bordent pèse plus lourd que l'ipad
pro et il est de combiner ensemble pèse
plus lourd qu'un macbook air mais vu le
système de fabrication vous êtes obligés
d'avoir quelque chose qui pèse lourd
pour venir contrebalancer le poids de
l'ipad pro point très positif apple
intègre et de l'usbc dans son magic qui
borde et vous êtes toujours le port usb
c'est de l'ipad fraude disponibles ce
qui fait que vous pouvez venir leurs
charges et d'un côté branché un
accessoire notre côté extrêmement
facilement vous allez pas avoir la même
vitesse de charge en passant par le
magic qui mordent quand le branchant
directement dans l'ipad pro mais ça ça
reste malgré tout du point de détail si
vous regardez
sur les bords de l'appareil ici eh bien
vous êtes vraiment à fleurs ce qui lui
donne un design qui est vraiment très
très très beau maintenant le problème
c'est que s'il tombe s'il prend un choc
et bien vous n'avez que très peu de
protection ici autant vous dire
quasiment aucune alors certes il faut
éviter faire tomber son ipad c'est pas
fait pour ça bien évidemment on est
malgré tout sur un magic qui bordent qui
sert également de protections de magic
codeurs on pourra appeler ça comme ça
sauf que la partie protection sera
effectivement bonne pour la face avant
mais également pour la face arrière
puisque vous voyez là que les caméras ne
dépasse pas mais par contre tout ce qui
va être un choc sur les côtés et bien
vous n'avez que très peu de protection
éviter quand même de jeter votre ipad
pour le tester pour vérifier ça pourrait
être relativement bas l'eau à la
question est-ce que l'ipad pro devient
un ordinateur grâce au magic qui bordent
j'ai envie de dire oui et non oui
beaucoup oui puisque vous voyez vous
avez beaucoup d' usage très similaire à
un ordinateur après ça dépend de quel
ordinateur ça dépend si on parle d'un
macbook air sa dépense on parle d'un
macbook pro ça dépend dans une fois de
plus de vos usages ça dépend vous ce que
vous allez réellement et concrètement
offert au quotidien ce qui est sûr c'est
que le magic qui bordent on mène l'ipad
pro dans d'autres sphères il va encore
plus loin il est encore plus complet et
je pense que beaucoup de personnes
il va se substituer à un ordinateur sur
les trois quarts des usages moi non
avec mes habitudes de montage et mon
travail ce pouvoir remplacer mon
macbookpro parents n'avaient pas de pros
avec un hadji qui mordent
néanmoins je peux vous assurer qu'il va
prendre une place de plus en plus
présente et de plus en plus croissante à
la maison que ce soit sur des usages de
bureautique sont les usages de
divertissement aussi bien pour moi que
pour reste de la famille bon je vais
éviter pour elliott à 6 ans qui me
[ __ ] en l'air ça c'est ce programme
dit promettant vous aller beaucoup plus
loin avec l'ipad pro que ce que
pouvaient faire jusqu'à présent
et moi je trouve ça vraiment bien
maintenant se retrouve un peu moins bien
c'est le prix puisque pour la version
ipad pro 11 pouces et coûtera 3 139
euros et pour la version 12 9 pouces
comme j'ai ici 399 euros c'est
relativement cher si on se dit c'est un
accessoire c'est très chiant pour un
accessoire mais si on voit que cet
accessoire vous permet de transformer
votre ipad pro en ordinateurs et que de
fait il n'est plus un accessoire mais
une extension votre ipad pro et bien on
peut mieux
comprendre le prix même si malgré tout
ça reste quand même un sacré budget a
vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire est ce que
vous avez en avait pas de pros est ce
que vous avez acheté le magic qui
bordent est ce que vous pourriez acheter
est ce que vous êtes sensible à ses
charmes est ce que vous voyez les usages
oui non quoi comment marquer moi tout ça
en bas en commentaire quant à nous on se
retrouve dès demain pour continuer à
parler de teck allez je vous envoie de
l'amour à demain ciao
[Musique]